how much can we override the
evolutionary desires with our sort of
cultural
fashions of the day that maybe represent
other
desirable aspects like wealth well
wealth is
resources have always been important
especially to women so is a man
able to acquire resources and is he
willing to dispense them to her and her
kids so that's always important in
traditional cultures that boils down to
hunting skills so
if uh so i have to uh call a friend kim
hill who's uh probably the world's
leading expert on the aceh of paraguay
and uh and you ask him like what what
leads to high status in the aceh in
males hunting skills that's that's nice
one the one thing the big variable and
that's resources and that's resources
now what's what's interesting about
modern cultures we have cash economies
but cash economies are relatively recent
um and
you know historically there's over the
vast
99 of human evolutionary history you
weren't able to stockpile resources in
the way that you are today
um
although there are interestingly certain
ways you can do it so so like you you
kill a large game animal okay you bring
it back you get some status points
because you
give some to your family you can share
it more widely with the group et cetera
um
but um but it's going to go bad right
you can't just say i'm going to keep
this carcass around for the next several
months okay but
and and i think okay i think it's a
steve pinker who might have used coin
this phrase that they they store the
meat in the bodies of other people and
so for example they store it in their
friends so you know um
hunting success is uh
you know it's it's a hit or miss kind of
thing so you might come back
empty-handed four times out of five
but and but when you do you share your
meat with others and then when
you know and then they reciprocate by
sharing their meat with you and so and
so you can store resources in the bodies
of other people which is i think an
interesting way to think about it but
that can only go so far and when you
have cash economies you have both the
ability to stockpile resources but also
this kind of explosion and
inequality of resources
and that's evolutionarily recent